je veux vous parler d'écouteurs que j'ai
reçu ces techniques qui m'a envoyé c'est
tout dernier écouteurs à la référence un
petit peu imbitable ce sont les az80 oui
c'est écrit ici a à Z80 je sais pas
pourquoi les constructeurs aiment bien
nous mettre des noms un peu compliqué au
niveau des produits mais je vous en
parle aujourd'hui parce que je les ai
vraiment aimé et que quand la technique
m'a dit tiens gros tu voudrais pas qu'on
t'envoie des écouteurs j'imagine on voit
on va acheter une oreille dessus on va
voir ce que ça raconte et je dois vous
avais que je suis franchement pas déçu
au début je pensais vous en faire plus
un short vous dire bah tiens il y a un
nouveau produit vous le montrer mais
vraiment vu ce que j'ai entendu j'avais
vraiment envie d'en faire une vidéo
longue de vous en parler de vous
expliquer sinon aujourd'hui une vidéo
qui n'est absolument pas réalisé en
partenariat avec que ce soit mais ça
fait trop plaisir de vous parler de ces
écouteurs qui sont très bien et puis de
toute façon vous le savez sur ma chaîne
les vidéos en partenariat il y en a mais
c'est pas du tout pléthore donc voilà
donc aujourd'hui je vous présente ces
nouveaux écouteurs et si vous avez un
budget de je voulais tout de suite c'est
marqué la noire sur blanc 299 balles
quasiment 300 € si vous voulez vraiment
être dans le haut de gamme au niveau de
l'audio je suis une des références qui a
pu très longtemps technique et je sais
pas si vous connaissez technique hein je
vais vous passer un peu l'histoire mais
technique pour tous ceux qui comme moi
aiment bien sortir on connaît les
platines il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
produits sont aussi très forts justement
au niveau de l'audio là dessus et je
dois reconnaître que franchement ça ça
envoie du bois allez on y va pas trop de
temps je vous envoie directement le
générique
ok alors techniquement envoyer ça dans
une énorme boîte il y avait ça dedans je
l'ai ouvert et en fait dans cet énorme
boite il y avait quoi alors il y avait
s'attaque une petite chiffonnette
histoire que ça brille et puis vous avez
surtout un petit chargeur parce que
ouais ils sont compatibles charge QI
charge sans fil alors je peux vous faire
la démo de je le branche et ça tag vous
le posez ça charge pour connait la
charge sans fil après bon ça c'est des
trucs à me dire acheter en plus ils
m'ont aussi envoyé une petite accessoire
pour le petit essuyer alors ça c'est un
DJ avec touché cuir je sais pas si c'est
vraiment du cuir je pense pas je sais
pas j'en sais rien allez savoir donc si
vous voulez avoir une petite étui et
fait cuire ou cuir peut-être tag vous le
prenez vous le mettez à votre ceinture
ça je trouve que ça fait un peu daté
d'un autre temps alors il y a un côté
très premium à avoir ça mais ça me fait
penser un peu à l'Américain qui met ça à
sa ceinture et qui se balade avec son
truc à côté je sais pas trop trop trop
trop fan je pense pas trop bon après
voilà il y en a pour tout le monde mais
bon si vous voulez ce sont des
accessoires qui existent on va
rapidement passer parce que c'est pas le
sujet aujourd'hui et qu'on s'en fout un
peu moi ce qui m'intéresserait
réellement c'est le produit parce que le
produit les couleurs avant de vous
parler du produit je vous montre un truc
très vraiment très très très bien c'est
qu'en fait technique ils ont vraiment un
peu penser à tout là-dessus et ça je
dois reconnaître que c'est aussi
vachement cool c'est alors déjà je vous
le montrer rapidement vous verrez vous
avez une application qui est super cool
compatible bien évidemment iPhone
iPad iPod mais bien évidemment Android
voyez la petite tronche juste en dessous
vous avez Alexa à l'intérieur mais pas
uniquement avec ça à l'intérieur je vais
vous expliquer ça dans quelques instants
le truc qui est cool je sais pas si
c'est votre cas d'ailleurs dites-le moi
tout de suite dans les commentaires il y
a plein de personnes qui galèrent avec
des bugs parce que vous avez peut-être
trois tailles généralement des couteaux
avoir trois quatre tailles vous avez le
médium vous avez le large vous avez le
plus fin des fois une taille
supplémentaire et on galère réellement
alors moi j'ai des oreilles qui ponce
coup de galère pas je prends je tourne
hop là ça me remets ma musique je
l'arrête directement et parce qu'un
petit capteur qui reconnaît en vous le
mettez dans votre oreille et si la
musique avait été mis avant PAF quand
vous l'enlevez ça vous l'arrête quand
vous la remettez ça vous mets play et là
hop la raid je retourne je suis dans
directement et moi ça tient bien j'ai
des oreilles un peu de monsieur et
madame tout le monde donc ça c'est
pratique mais si vous avez pas des
oreilles de monsieur et madame tout le
monde alors il y a pas réellement de
monsieur madame tout le monde au niveau
de notre anatomie mais moi j'ai les
oreilles un peu pas commune genre c'est
foutrement rien mais en tout cas le
médium ça me va bien si vous avez pas
des oreilles qui sont vraiment adaptées
aux médium et ben là c'est cool ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'en fait il y en
a pour beaucoup de personnes et ça ça me
plaît bien donc ça c'est cool donc moi
mon médium il est juste là là vous avez
du large là vous avez de l'extrait large
là vous avez une espèce de taille
intermédiaire un petit small small-1
small 2 donc vous voyez il y a vraiment
des tailles intermédiaires l'extra small
2 et l'extra small 1 donc vous voyez en
fait en fonction de l'oreille de chacun
c'est pas mal fichu cela ils sont un peu
plus longs ceux-là ils sont un poil plus
courts là c'est pareil au niveau du
Small un peu plus long un peu plus court
pour que ça puisse rentrer dans les
oreilles de tout le monde donc ça c'est
bien parce que si vous aimez le format
Bud et que vous avez jamais la taille
qui vous correspond et ben pour le coup
je dois reconnaître que là ils ont fait
un truc très cool donc ça c'est bien
donc ça déjà c'est un bon point
là-dessus ensuite à l'intérieur vous
allez avoir un petit câble un petit
manuel bon ok c'est simple ça va bien
là-dessus il y a pas grand chose à me
raconter moi le truc qui va vraiment
m'intéresser c'est ce qui se passe ici
alors vous avez effectivement une petite
boîte avec sur le dessus et ça c'est
marrant là il y a un côté métal qui nous
ont mis ici on sent c'est beaucoup plus
froid voilà ça c'est du plastoc c'est
tout de suite beaucoup plus chaud donc
vous avez plastique métal vous avez un
petit mélange alors là c'est le modèle
noir il existe un modèle blanc si vous
préférez le blanc et après c'est des
bulles un peu classique avec un petit
voyant ici un petit voyant également sur
le dessus vous voyez il se connecte ils
viennent se mettre dans vos oreilles
indicateur de présence ou non quoi
comment petite comment tactile que vous
avez sur le dessus et bon voilà ça c'est
simple c'est bien c'est joli donc ça
c'est un peu pour tout le côté un peu
matériel qu'on va venir retrouver à
savoir qu'en plus et si c'est cool vous
avez des drivers de 10 mm avec un
diaphragme en aluminium à bord libre bon
on va pas rentrer dans le côté trop
technique parce que c'est rapidement
rébarbatif mais le truc moi qui m'a
vraiment impressionné ici c'est la
qualité audio c'est-à-dire que lorsque
vous les mettez et je vais vous montrer
j'ai tout mis dans mon application là
sur le Galaxy S23 ultra l'équaliseur de
base il est neutre il est bien ça marche
bien et vous avez vraiment un mode qui
vient monter le niveau de la qualité
audio qui est vraiment top ce que j'aime
beaucoup ici au niveau de la qualité
audio c'est que le son est très précis
et très maîtrisé quel que soit les
bandes de fréquences déjà vous avez un
spectre qui est très large les graves
sont ronds sont beaux sont précis ils
vont pas baver pareil vous avez des
médiums d'une extrême précision très
très jolie et les aigus pareil très fins
ça va pas siffler vous avez pas de de
sifflante vers les 7 kg Hertz bref c'est
beau c'est bien maîtrisé ça me plaît et
surtout ici vous avez vraiment une belle
dynamique au niveau du son va encaisser
il va pas saturer donc ça c'est chouette
une fois de plus ça c'est un peu pour la
base le début alors bon je vais pas moi
l'écouter vous raconter des miens mais
c'est vraiment un truc à venir ici c'est
vraiment très très chouette et après
tout le reste ça va se passer dans
l'application parce que l'application
elle joue vraiment un rôle extrêmement
important ici alors mon application elle
est planquée juste ici regarde alors au
moment où je tourne je suis sous embargo
donc c'est une apk j'ai installé hop
audio Connect donc là il faut que je
mette mon casque voilà là je l'ai mis à
l'oreille connectée donc connexion du
casque il vous met le niveau de batterie
que vous avez en haut ça c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal donc là il est en
train de se connecter je vais mettre le
deuxième aussi peut-être comme ça au
moins j'aurai mon deuxième niveau de
batterie également là voilà
98%, 99% 40% pour mon étui je vois
exactement j'en suis j'ai le nom du
produit et ensuite j'ai quelques petits
raccourcis qui sont intéressants
contrôle du son ambiant tac tac donc là
vous avez soit vous coupez la réduction
de bruit ou le mode transparent ce que
je vous recommande parce que je vais
mettre le son en lui pour m'entendre
parler bah ça sera beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs je vais le monter un petit
peu plus comme ça je m'attendrai encore
mieux ça va m'aider un petit peu il y a
un son un petit peu pas naturel à
métallique lorsque je viens m'entendre
comme ça c'est pas ouf et là hop là le
mode transparent alors ça je vais vous
montrer tout à l'heure en fait je me
mets en mode désactivé lorsque j'écoute
la musique ici je suis chez moi j'ai pas
trop de pollution audio donc je me mets
là pourquoi parce que lorsque vous
mettez la réduction de bruit elle vient
quand même bouffer un peu de fréquence
et ça vient réduire un petit peu je vois
pas comment vous expliquer imaginez que
vous aviez par exemple un oursin vous
imaginez un oursin avec toutes les pics
de l'oursin et en fait toutes les pics
de l'oursin ça va être la profondeur des
fréquences c'est-à-dire que vous avez
sur la gauche le son très grave de votre
oursin sur le dessus et bien toutes les
pics du dessus ça va être tout le son
médium et sur la droite ça va être
toutes les fréquences aiguë imaginez que
lorsque vous êtes en mode désactivé vous
avez toutes les pics de l'oursin qui
vont bien jusqu'en haut et lorsque vous
mettez la réduction de bruit et bien
c'est comme si vous prenez une tondeuse
et que vous coupiez tout le haut ou j'en
sais rien une scie vous coupiez un petit
peu le haut vous venir raboter un petit
peu le haut des pics de l'ours donc vous
êtes toujours votre son mais en fait vos
pics elles vont un peu moins loin et ça
vient bouffer un petit peu de son et
c'est vraiment ce qu'on a ici avec cette
réduction de bruit qui même si elle fait
le taf et même si la qualité reste bonne
attention il y a pas de souci si malgré
tout ça rabote un poil et ça vient
enlever un peu je dirais aux détails sur
les fréquences quel que soit les
fréquences donc bon c'est bien ça permet
d'écouter la musique sans être pollué
par l'environnement extérieur mais si
vous voulez vraiment maximiser
l'expérience écouter tout votre enceinte
je vous recommande de vous mettre en
désactivé c'est ce qui est mieux parce
que dès que vous mettez de
l'électronique sont bien aux réduction
oui on vient bouffer un peu les
fréquences alors regardez il y a un truc
intéressant c'est à dire
qu'effectivement vous le voyez déjà sur
votre son ambiant là et bien vous pouvez
venir moduler qu'est-ce que je veux
injecter comme volume de son ambiant par
rapport à mes besoins donc ça c'est cool
c'est complètement personnalisable donc
là je m'entends à fond et que ce soit un
peu métallique là je m'entends quand
même un petit peu là forcément moins et
là je m'entends moi parler dans ma tête
c'est comme si je l'avais désactivé vous
voyez je désactive alors je désactive ça
coupe carrément plus là j'entends un
mini truc un petit peu je sens que j'ai
réinjecté mais c'est vraiment vraiment
pas grand chose du poil de cul et
ensuite je viens monter là et après vous
avez l'autre mode qui est intéressant
c'est le mode transparent alors le mode
transparent et vous le disent les sons
qui vous entourent ne sont pas modifiés
attention la musique en pause fait
ressortir la voix des conversations des
annonces en fait si vous mettez le mode
attention ça va pousser davantage ça va
vraiment creuser les médiums en fait sur
votre bande de fréquence ça pousse
vraiment des médiums je pense vers un
kilo pas loin d'un kilo parce que le son
est vraiment vraiment intéressant de
parler comme ça en fait si vous voulez
donc là ça vient vraiment pousser ça le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que si
vous êtes j'en sais rien moi dans le
métro vous êtes dans le train vous êtes
dans une gare vous êtes dans un avion
vous voulez entendre les annonces et
bien vous allez entendre les annonces
mais bon au-delà de ça le son est quand
même un peu dégueu on va pas se mentir
désactiver je vous explique réduction de
bruit dans la réduction de bruit à
l'intéressant parce que de la même
manière sur le son ambiant là vous voyez
vous venez régler la réduction de bruit
que vous allez venir injecter en
réduction de bruit donc là je suis au
max et là j'en ai un petit peu moins
donc je fais des petites tests et je
tape sur ma table vous voyez et ben ça
va venir casser un petit peu le son qui
arrive jusque dans mes oreilles à savoir
que plus j'envoie je t'en ai quand même
un petit peu voyez je tendrai plus du
médium que là si j'arrive là j'ai du
médium avec un petit peu plus de gras
voyez j'ai mon spectre qui s'élargit
légèrement comme si j'avais ma pointe
qui était un peu moins fine au niveau du
son que je vais venir injecter au niveau
de mon équaliseur bref je peux vous
perdre là-dessus donc voilà au niveau de
la réduction donc moi la réduction de
bruit elle est bonne elle marche bien
elle est cool donc ça c'est très très
chouette et ensuite alors si vous venez
fouiller un peu plus dans l'application
vous voyez que vous avez des petits
menus en bas alors on va voir l'accueil
l'accueil sur lequel on arrivé je
voulais montrer la réduction de bruit
avant de vous montrer les autres petits
menus en bas je vais vous montrer le
reste donc là je suis sur le dynamique
dynamique ça m'emmène sur mon équaliseur
et mon équaliseur elle est cool alors
moi ce que je vous recommande par défaut
vous arrivez ici c'est à dire que vous
avez le son direct flat c'est le mix que
vous a fait l'ingénieur du son lorsqu'il
a mixé avec la masterisation qui a été
fait au-dessus on passe un petit peu et
après vous avez différentes possibilités
soit vous venez vraiment booster les
graves ou alors vous aimez carrément
vous booster davantage les graves si on
veut écouter que de l'électro ou du
hip-hop vraiment que ça tartine là soit
les voix vous venez vraiment monter les
médium c'est assez doux je tiens à
préciser parce que des fois j'ai écouté
des équaliseurs et vous mettez des trucs
ça dénaturer ça vient pousser des
fréquences mais ça dénature pas donc ils
sont bien bossé le recue ici leur a pris
elle est bonne et là ça vient pousser
les aigus moi ce que je vous recommande
vraiment c'est le mode dynamique parce
que le mode dynamique vous le voyez il
vient augmenter les graves il vient
casser un peu sur les fréquences médium
grave je pense vers le 600 600 800 kg à
mon avis il vient vous remonter
légèrement vers le 1 Kg 1 kg de 1 kg
vous casse un petit peu vers le 3 kg et
après il remonté carrément pour vous
ramener des fréquences plus aiguës et
vous RAM un petit peu de précision et
franchement c'est très très beau et
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'ils ont fait ici
au niveau de ce côté dynamique parce que
ça me rapporte vraiment plus de graves
plus de rondeurs j'écoutais plein de
styles de musique mais ça me permet
vraiment de la rondeur j'ai ma voix qui
ressort et ça c'est bien et puis j'ai de
la précision mes aigus mais ça balle
toutes mes autres fréquences même des
fois quand j'écoute des cordes de
guitare j'ai vraiment touché de la corde
je ressens la corde et j'ai la précision
un peu au niveau du doigt je sens
vraiment toute cette finesse et ça
j'aime beaucoup donc ça c'est vraiment
bien bosser le personnaliser si vous le
souhaitez et vous amuser avec vos bandes
de fréquence il y en a pas énormément
hein vous voyez vous avez du sang et
Halse 315 1 kg 3 kg 15 et 10 kg bon
franchement je vous le recommande pas ce
que je vous conseille c'est le mode
dynamique pour moi il marche bien ça
c'est très très bien alors si on
continue ici alors vous avez votre
option vous allez retrouver votre casque
si vous l'avez perdu et bien vous
appuyez il émet un son vous le retrouvez
bon on connaît grâce à la localisation
également et après vous avez un autre
mode qui est très cool aussi qui
s'appelle just my voice alors là il vous
en revient un petit tuto pour venir le
faire le mettre ici et ça ça je l'ai
fait le petit tuto mais en fait ce que
je vais vous expliquer c'est que just my
boss il est pas mal pourquoi parce qu'en
fait ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
lorsque vous êtes dans un environnement
où beaucoup de bruit alors il y a deux
possibilités soit on veut écouter de la
musique auquel cas mais la réduction de
bruit active et là ça marche ça vous
coupe il y a pas de souci mais si vous
parlez avec quelqu'un au téléphone on
veut pas forcément que la personne est
bien elle galère à vous comprendre parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de bruit à l'eau tu
m'entends tu me comprends voilà je dois
vous écouteurs ils sont là vos micro ils
sont là il y a 8 micros tout expliqué
dans quelques instants et bien en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
justement et bien le fait que vous ayez
8 micros ici ça vient vraiment
travailler pour cette question de Just
myvoice c'est à dire que Joyce myvoice
ça va garder uniquement votre voix ça va
reconnaître votre voix au moment où vous
parlez vous avez un algo intelligent qui
comprend que vous parlez probablement
parce qu'il y a aussi un mouvement
biomécanique et qui va venir le
reconnaître surtout par rapport à la
fréquence donc il sait qu'elle a
fréquence à moins son de votre voix tac
il concentre sur votre voix et ensuite
quand vous avez fini de parler qui coupe
directement donc pour la personne qui va
vous entendre et qui va venir converser
avec vous et bien elle va vraiment se
concentrer sur votre voix et ça c'est
cool parce que c'est assez bluffant en
fait et ça marche vachement bien alors
je vous le disais en fait par écouteur
vous avez 4 micros 8 microns en tout
vous avez alors je sais pas exactement
ils n'ont pas détailler leur sauce
technique mais en fait ce qu'ils font
c'est que vous êtes d'abord deux micros
qui vont venir travailler pour capter le
son de votre voix de micro qui vont se
focuser sur le son environnant et qui
peuvent un système de hors phase et
peut-être un système de gate allait
savoir en tout cas ça va venir couper à
un moment et vous êtes tranquille donc
ça c'est cool et ça marche bien donc ça
c'est une techno que je trouve aussi
supra intéressantes et hyper cool donc
just myvoice à venir vraiment essayer de
tester parce que c'est très cool et puis
après vous voyez vous avez d'autres
modes en bas ambiance à vous ramène sur
votre réduction de bruit mode de
transparent et si ça sont ça vous ramène
à venir choisir votre écume en fait
c'est les raccourci que vous avez là
vous voyez vous les avez ici et ici et
après vous avez plein de petits réglages
qui sont aussi pas mal du tout alors
vous choisissez votre langue fatalement
je l'ai mis en français par défaut il
est en anglais personnalisé un invite
vocal le volume l'annonce lors du
changement de mode également est-ce que
vous voulez un centre de notification
est-ce que vous voulez le nom du mode
moi j'ai mis le nom du mode c'est ce que
je préfère vous avez ensuite le nom du
casque la couleur du casque bon je vois
pas trop à quoi ça sert mettre la
couleur du casque mais bon vous mettez
la couleur de votre casque action donc
ajouter un casque si vous voulez vous
avez plein de casques différents chez
Technics qui sont ici trouver le casque
c'est la même chose que tout à l'heure
je voulais montrer directement le
système alors vous avez la mise hors
tension automatique toujours activer ou
vous choisissez lorsqu'il y a de
l'inactivité au bout de 5 10 30 60
minutes c'est pour venir économiser
votre batterie capteur de port de casque
ça c'est pas mal donc lorsque votre
casque n'est plus porté vous voyez que
il vous propose donc de mettre la
lecture en poste c'est plutôt pratique
donc vous l'enlevez tac tac qui se met
en pause OK et de reprendre la lecture
lorsque vous le remettez en place moins
d'une minute plutôt pas mal donc voyez
toutes ces petites options assez fines
ce qui montre que technique ça a bien
bossé à réfléchir surtout son
application donc ça c'est bien pendant
que le casque est retiré les commandes
sont plus acceptées vous pouvez
également lui dire que les commandes
sont acceptées lorsque le casque est
retiré ce qui veut dire qu'en fait
lorsque vous avez retiré vos écouteurs
et bien votre pavé tactile reste actif
donc c'est à dire vous allez pouvoir
faire un morceau suivant morceau
précédent et compagnie je suis pas
convaincu moi je préfère les désactiver
si je l'ai pas c'est qu'il y a une
raison donc ça c'est le premier point
ensuite vous allez arriver sur Connecter
le mode de connexion ça c'est quand même
pas mal fichier donc là vous avez soit
entre deux options soit priorité à la
qualité du son soit priorité à la
connectivité personnellement je préfère
prioriser la qualité du son ici et j'ai
même poussé le helldac parce qu'en fait
si vous le mettez pas vous avez soit du
AAC soit du SBC si vous n'avez pas de
codec de Qualcomm c'est vraiment soit à
AC soit SBC soit le l-d alors moi j'ai
voulu pousser le Elda qui m'offrira la
meilleure qualité je vais aller jusqu'à
96 kHz 24 bits donc super qualité audio
et c'est vrai que c'est ce que je
préfère là j'aurai la meilleure qualité
par contre je vais venir perdre en
termes de latence si je veux venir
regarder par exemple un film une série
en rouge et de la vidéo et de l'audio en
même temps il se peut que j'ai un
décalage si je veux pas de décalage je
vais éviter de mettre le helldaq c'est
vraiment pour venir écouter de la
musique donc bon je l'ai mis mais je
peux venir désactiver vous voyez comme
ça tac tac tac et et hop il me le
désactive donc là il redémarre et
ensuite je peux choisir directement
voyez priorité à la connectivité
priorité à la qualité du son ensuite
vous avez une multipoint ça c'est
intéressant pourquoi parce que le du
coup en fait ça vous permet de connecter
vos écouteurs à trois sources
différentes maximum trois sources
différentes ce qui fait que si vous êtes
sur votre smartphone en train d'écouter
de la musique PAF vous allez sur votre
ordinateur pas vous switcher sur une
tablette vous pouvez le faire ça c'est
plutôt cool donc en multipoint soit vous
mettez un seul appareil auquel cas et
bien il vous le recommande lorsque vous
utilisez le ldaq c'est là où vous
montrez en 96 kg Hertz 24 bits donc là
on vous le propose c'est ce qu'il y a de
mieux vous pouvez aller jusqu'à deux
appareils vu les changer la qualité de
lecture elle date pour l'appareil de
lecture sur qualité de lecture optimale
et puis là trois appareils on n'utilise
pas le ldaq donc ça c'est pour votre
multipoint donc à vous de voir ce dont
vous aurez besoin d'un appareil deux
appareils trois appareils peut-être ou
pas du tout allez savoir en tout cas
pour lui dire dans l'application le
modifier directement et puis ensuite
vous arrivez sur Suppression des délais
et des interruptions du son et alors là
c'est intéressant aussi parce que il
vous le mettre sur Automatique ce
réglage est recommandé lorsque vous
utilisez le l DAC effectue un réglage
automatique pour supprimer
l'interruption du son cependant l'écart
entre la vidéo et l'audio peut augmenter
donc là typiquement ça il faut
l'utiliser lorsque vous venez écouter
que de la musique parce que si vous
écoutez de la musique il faut regarder
de la vidéo temps vous allez avoir un
délai c'est à dire vous voyez que ça
bouge là et en même temps le son va pas
être synchronisé donc ça c'est
relativement relou donc la supprimer
l'interruption du son donc là vous
choisissez carrément de le supprimer
l'interruption du son donc réduit
l'interruption du son recommandée pour
la musique le délai entre la vidéo et le
dos peut-être augmenter donc ça on le
garde uniquement pour la musique et
après si vous voulez supprimer le délai
du son c'est-à-dire que l'audio et la
vidéo soit vraiment synchronisée et bien
vous passez là-dessus par contre il vous
le marque si la qualité de lecture elle
date de l'appareil de lecture est réglé
sur optimisé pour la qualité audio 990
909 KB par seconde alors nous
recommandons de régler sur qualité de
lecture optimale en fait ce qu'il faut
faire c'est que si vous voulez la
meilleure qualité audio vous mettez en
automatique et vous venez mettre le
helldak si par contre vous voulez
regarder une vidéo vous mettez supprimer
le délai du son et vous me supprimer le
helldac et vous venez prioriser surtout
pour avoir regardé vous venez là en mode
de connexion et vous mettez priorité à
la collectivité comme ça vous êtes sûr
vous aurez une vraie bonne synchro entre
l'audio et la vidéo et ici pas de
mauvaise surprise et puis après pour
venir personnaliser également les
commandes tactiles c'est vachement bien
parce que très int comment en général et
les commandes du téléphone comment le
général voyez j'appuie et ensuite j'ai
les grandes icônes qui me permettent de
voir ce que je veux faire donc là c'est
sur un seul tapotement lecture post
est-ce que j'ai et après je peux venir
choisir morceau précédent morceau
suivant monter le volume baisser le
volume commutateur de contrôle de son
ambioréduction de bruit sont ambiant
désactiver le son bien ou alors
carrément aucune fonction c'est très
très bien et en plus vous avez la même
chose pour le téléphone j'appelle je
réponds si et ça donc ça c'est cool
c'est très très simple et très intuitif
réglage de la commande de son ambiant
également donc là je peux choisir
réduction de bruit son ambiant que là il
est pas activé je viens l'activer je
switch entre mes trois modes je
sauvegarde réglage de mode en bio mode
transparent le mode attention également
qu'on peut venir choisir donc on met
soit l'un soit l'autre bon j'ai mis le
mode transparent c'est pas une mode
attention j'utilise pas des masses mais
si vous voulez vous pouvez venir
l'activer directement optimisation de la
réduction du bruit très réglage donc là
vous pouvez venir régler vous
directement pour avoir votre réduction
de bruit sur le pré réglage moi je les
poussais à fond parce que je veux que ça
réduise au maximum niveau de réduction
du bruit ambiant soit je le veux normal
soit je le vois fort bon je l'ai mis en
mode normal ici parce que je vous le
disque si vous le passez en fort il se
peut que les retraites interlocuteur
soit entrecoupés ça veut vraiment coupé
coupé pour garder que des bouts de voix
en fait parler comme ta coupe c'est
relou donc non on le veut pas et puis
vous sélectionnez votre assistant vocal
soit Amazon Alexa soit l'assistant vocal
du téléphone soit vous les activer moi
j'ai mis celui du téléphone comme ça je
choisis ce que je veux ça me va bien et
puis après l'entretien des conseils
notifications d'entretien manuel guidée
compagnie donc vous voyez ce qui est
super ici c'est que j'ai des écouteurs
de super bonne qualité sont vraiment
très cool une bonne réduction de bruit
une application extrêmement complète en
règle générale je dirais que si vous
prenez un beau par exemple chez Bose
c'est un peu le mode tout est
automatique on vient pas trop gratuit
dans les paramètres si vous prenez un
Sony c'est un peu l'inverse c'est plus
le truc du Geek on vient gratuit dans
les paramètres on aime bien venir
gratouiller bah la technique c'est un
peu la même philosophie c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut aller assez loin au niveau
des paramètres régler pas mal de choses
l'application est vraiment intuitive
j'aime beaucoup ces écouteurs que je
trouve très cool ce truc que j'aime pas
des masses c'est la référence que je
trouve juste un bitable une fois de plus
on se parle bien ici du a à Z80 que je
viens vraiment vous recommander je vous
dis le tarif est assez élevé et pour
autant la qualité elle est vraiment très
cool alors on va juste parler de
l'autonomie l'autonomie alors ici
technique nous annonce jusqu'à 7h30
d'autonomie par écoute réduction de
bruit coupé et si vous activez la
réduction de bruit et bien vous allez
jusqu'à 7h d'autonomie et si vous le
passez dans les tuiles plusieurs fois
vous montez jusqu'à 25 heures d'écoute
sans venir le charger ici réduction de
bruit coupé 24 heures et 4 heures
d'appel téléphonique réduction de bruit
activé et avec le just my voice activé
également donc autant vous dire qu'ici
vous avez globalement de quoi faire sans
aucun problème autonomie est bonne et
dernier détail pour la route ils sont
certifiés IPX4 donc si vous transpirez
vous allez faire du sport avec il y a
absolument aucun problème la tenue est
très bonne également enfin vous avez
trouvé la taille qui vous convient bien
au niveau de votre silicone je pense que
c'est du silicone ici et bien ça fera
l'affaire et vous n'êtes pas vous marrer
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous
raconter aujourd'hui sur ces nouveaux
écouteurs de technique très haut de
gamme relativement cher 299 euros mais
par contre qui me convainc et énormément
je les aime beaucoup donc dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu en audio des produits de
technique oui non quoi comment vous
marquez ça dans les commentaires et puis
nous on se retrouve bientôt bien
évidemment pour parler de texte hein
c'est cool je vous embrasse bisous Ciao
[Musique]